Ideologies are fragmented,
religions are essentially,
they use the same symbolic under
structured,
but they only tell part of the story.
I can give you a quick example of that.
I'll do it very quickly.
So when the American West was settled,
it was settled on the.
On the wave of an ideological story,
and here's the story.
Heroic individual that's positive,
bringing positive culture.
That's the wise king into virgin
oriented,
chaotic territory.
That's the negative mother essentially.
So that's positive individual,
positive culture,
negative nature,
right,
and that's.
That's a motivating story,
man.
To bring heroically,
bring order into the untamed wilderness.
It's like a million people a year from
Europe.
Come driven by that narrative.
It's,
okay,
well here's the counter narrative raping
and pillaging individual bringing the
desolations of tyrannical culture into
the virginal,
wonderful environmental.
What?
What would you call it?
A hystopia of nature.
It's like,
yeah man,
you can get a long way with that story
too,
but they're both half the story,
so you just put those two things
together and you have a religious story.
It's like while the individual is heroic
but also is an adversary and accrual
adversary at that culture is the wise
king,
but it's also the evil tyrant and nature
is beautiful and wonderful friendship,
impressionistic landscape and cancer and
anopheles mosquitoes and they
elephantiasis and so if you are properly
oriented in the world,
you tell yourself both those stories and
you say,
Oh my God,
they conflict.
It's like,
yeah,
they do,
man.
That's exactly right.
So an etiology just pulls out a subset
of the religious characters and says,
this is the entire reality.
It's like,
no,
it's not.
It's a parasitical.
It's a parasitical meme.
Essentially an ideology is a parasitical
meme on a religious substructure.